Transcriber: Metin Akın
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Kiminize göre bir
kiminize göre de sonsuz
noktadan oluşuyor bir çember.
Bunun cevabını bir metaforla
size aktarıyor olacağım.
Sade ve kolay uygulanabilir bir model
ve bunu işinizde ve özelde de
kullanabileceksiniz.
Peki, nerede başlamıştı bu
noktanın hikâyesi?
Yıllar önce, Türkiye, İstanbul’da.
Bir sahne karşısında olacağım.
Küçük bir grup
ve ilk liderlik adaylık
deneyimimi yaşıyor olacağım.
Çok heyecanlıyım.
Ayaklarım tir tir titriyor.
Arkadaş ortamı.
Ona rağmen ölmek üzereyim.
Adım anons ediliyor,
benim için karanlık bir dünya,
hatırlamıyorum ne olduğunu.
Ne vadettiysem alkışlıyordu arkadaşlarım
ve böylece ilk deneyimimi yaşamıştım.
Çok sonraları öğreniyorum
ki aslında sahnede olmak,
topluluk önünde konuşmak,
korkuların en büyüğüymüş.
Ben de böylece ilk adımımı
ve kendimi de yenmek üzere
ilk hareketimi başlatmıştım.
Aldığım o destekle pek çok
projeyi hayata geçirdik.
Bu beni iki yıl sonra
bu sefer doğuya, Japonya’ya taşıdı.
Osaka’da büyük bir
akvaryumun karşısındayım.
Sükûnet ve sessizlik var.
Ta ki bir tanesi atlayana kadar.
Sonrasında müthiş bir curcuna,
akvaryumda atlayan atlayana.
Tahmin edeceğiniz gibi burası,
bir penguenler dünyasıydı
ve diğerleri atlamak için
ilk penguenin atlamasını beklemişti.
Orada bir şeyi daha fark ettim.
Evet liderlikse konu, ilerlemekse
söz konusu olan husus,
o zaman birisinin atlaması gerekiyordu.
Benim de dünya başkanlığına yönelik
vizyonum orada şekillenmeye başladı.
O zaman birisinin bunu
gerçekleştirmesi gerekiyordu.
Atlaması ilerlemesi ve beraber onu başarıp
gerçekleştirmemiz gerekiyordu.
Adım adım ilerledik
ve iki yıl sonra bu sefer batıda,
Brezilya’dayım.
Rio’da daha büyük bir topluluk
ve evet gerçekleşiyor.
Dünya başkan adaylık
konuşmamı yapıyor olacağım.
Sahneye çıkıyorum.
Günaydın!
Merhaba, ben İsmail.
Ama arkadaşlarım bana:
"I smile" diyorlar, dedim.
Yüzlerde bir gülümseme.
Bundan çok kısa bir süre önce,
o sabah kahvaltı yapıyoruz.
Bir arkadaşım bize yanaştı
ve dedi ki, “Can I Smile?”
Gülebilir miyim?
İzin istiyor bizden.
Sabahın sekizinde.
Baktık birbirimize, tabii ki, "you sure."
Bir kez daha sordu.
"Can I Smile?"
Birbirimize baktık, tabii ki dedik.
Bir kez daha “Gülebilir miyim?"
diye soruyor.
Bir sıkıntı var ama
lütfen gülebilirsin diyoruz.
Aslında sorun arkadaşım değilmiş,
sorun bizlermişiz.
Can’la İsmail yan yana oturuyor
ve bizim isimliklerimizi okuyor.
Can oluyor “Can”,
İsmail oluyor “I Smile”.
Böylece “Can I Smile” ortaya çıkıyor.
Sahnede liderliğe adayım dedim.
Evet.
İyiliği yaymaya ve yüzünüzdeki
gülümsemeler gibi
bu pozitif enerjiyi her noktaya taşımaya,
benimle var mısınız?
Vaat net ve benden çıkmaya başlamıştı.
Çünkü İsmail, "I Smile"
olmuştu o sahnede.
Sizden konu çıkmaya başladığında,
büyük bir sahiplenme
ve beraber çalışma ortaya çıkıyor.
Bu beni liderliğe taşımıştı.
Organizasyon liderliğini yapmak
ayrı bir mucizevi olaydı benim için
çünkü yüz yılda bir
başınıza gelir derler ya olay.
Benim için öyleydi.
Organizasyonun 100'üncü
yılında liderliğini yapacaktım.
Beklenti büyük,
100'ün üzerinde ülkeye gitmek,
seyahat etmek, projelere bakmak.
Yeni yüz yıla,
ikinci yüz yılın organizasyonunu
hazırlamaya başlamak.
Bu deneyim bana pek çok
başka katkı daha sundu.
Peki.
Bu seyahatim sırasında bir soru
aklıma gelmeye ve şekillenmeye başladı.
Kimi organizasyonlar,
kimi kurumlar,
kimi başlattığımız girişimler,
yüzyıllarca devam edebiliyorken,
yıllarca devam edebiliyorken,
bazı projeler de hemen bitiyor.
Birkaç yıllarını görmeden, birkaç
ayını bile görmeden ortadan kayboluyor.
Burada bir sır olsa gerek.
O zaman benim de bu deneyimimin
bunu çözmek üzere bir formül
ortaya koyması gerekiyor.
İşte nokta ve çemberin hikâyesi
buradan çıkmaya başladı.
Çünkü buradan fark etmeye başladığımı
modellemeye başlamıştım.
Müsaadenizle bunu birkaç tane
adımla size aktarıyor olacağım.
Özünde beş tane adım aktaracağım.
Birinci adım nokta olmakla ilgiliydi.
Çünkü bizler bir konuya
karar verdiğimizde
ve o kararı verdikten sonra
kendimize inandığımızda,
kendimizle bir kontrat imzaladığımızda,
bir nokta olarak ortaya çıkıyoruz.
Ortada görünüyor oluyoruz,
artık biz varız diyoruz.
İşte bu noktanın hikâyesi.
Bu noktanın hikâyesi ve model çok önemli.
Çünkü istatistikler de şunu gösteriyor:
başlatılan her türlü organizasyon
beş yıl sonra varlığını sürdürmüyor.
Beşte biri ancak devamlılığını
ve sürekliliğini sağlıyor.
O zaman hareket başlatmak lazım,
yeni çalışmaları ortaya koymak gerekiyor.
Peki, sadece nokta yeterli mi?
Hareketi başlatmak için evet.
Ama sizin, bir çember çizmeniz gerekiyor.
Çember sizin vizyonunuzu,
ulaşmak istediğiniz yeri,
biraz da oyun alanınızı tarifliyor.
Bunu çizdiğiniz noktada, kendiniz
için de her şey netleşmeye başlıyor.
Ne yapacağınız?
Nereye gideceğiniz?
Sizin için berraklaşıyor.
Bunu gördüğünüz yerde,
bu sefer hem lidere hem de vizyona,
çembere inanmaya başlayan
takımdaşlarınız olmaya,
sizlerle beraber bu yolu yürüyecek,
kan, ter, gözyaşı demeden
bunu başarmak için çalışacak
arkadaşlarınız dahil olmaya başlıyor.
Adım adım ve bu ekip büyüyor.
İşte burada, ekibin büyümesiyle
beraber, vizyona ve lidere inanç var.
Üçüncü adım ise, sizin yavaş yavaş
bunu yönetmeye başlamanız.
Bu, lider yetiştirmeye
başlamanız anlamına geliyor.
Siz bir noktaydınız ve bir yeri
işgal ediyordunuz.
O işgal ettiğiniz yerden
dışarı çıkmanız gerekiyor.
Dışarı çıkabilmeniz için de
orayı doldurmanız.
Sizden daha iyi,
bunu daha ileriye taşıyacak
ve lider yetiştireceğiniz bir husus.
Bunu yaptığınız takdirde
bu sefer çemberi yönetmeye başlarsınız.
Çemberin üzerine gelmiş olursunuz.
Bu, yönetim açısından
çok kıymetli bir adım olacaktır.
Genelde oraya geldiğimizde,
bizler bir adım geriye gitmek isteriz.
Hani daha iyi biliyoruz ya,
hani öğretmek istiyoruz ya.
Bunu yapmaya başladığımızda
orayı yıkabiliriz.
İlerlememiz gereken aslında dördüncü adım.
Bu çemberin dışına doğru
çıkabilmek, tam tersi yönde.
Çünkü çemberin içinde kaldığınız müddetçe,
siz yeni bir şeyler üretemezsiniz.
Çemberin dışına çıktığınızda,
yeni şeyler üretmeye başlayabilirsiniz.
Bu sebeple, çemberin dışına çıkabilmek,
çok önemli ve kıymetli bir adım olacak.
Bu metafor, noktadan çembere
ve çemberden dışarıya
çıkmayı özetliyor bizlere.
Biz bir çember tariflediğimizde,
ne yaptığımızı biliyoruz.
Nereye ulaşmak istediğimizi de biliyoruz.
Şayet onun içerisinde kalacaksak,
buna odaklanmalı
ve bunu en iyi şekilde yapmalıyız.
İki yarım bir tam etmez,
bunu sakın unutmayın.
O odaklandığınız şeyi
en iyi şekilde yapmanız gerekiyor.
Çünkü sizin tek çemberiniz o olacak.
Ama daha çok şey yapmak,
çoğalmak istiyorsanız
mutlaka dışına çıkmanız gerekiyor.
İşte, sistemlerin burada
oluştuğunu fark ediyorum.
Çünkü bir nokta olarak
hareket başlatmak için yeterliyiz.
Evet başlatabiliriz,
zaten bu sebeple, pek çok girişim,
pek çok oluşum hayata geçiyor.
Ama bunun sürekliliğini sağlamak için
ekipler ve sistemler kurmak gerekiyor.
Sistem kurmadığınız müddetçe,
siz dışına çıkıp sürekliliğini
sağlamadığınız müddetçe,
sizin başlatmış olduğunuz
çalışma devam etmiyor.
Bunu liderliğim sonrasında
özelimde de denedim
ve aynı zamanda
yeni oluşturduğum dış çemberlerim,
diğer çemberlerimde de denedim.
Liderliğimi takip eden süre sonrasında,
iki yıl kadar sonra
bir girişim hareketi daha başlattık.
Bu başlatmış olduğumuzda da
benzer şekilde birdik beş olduk,
beştik yirmi beş olduk.
Çoğalıyoruz, yurt içine yurt dışına
pek çok yere yayılıyoruz.
Model basit, sade
ve her yere uygulanabilir.
Şayet siz dışarı çıktığınızda,
şu kararı veriyor olursunuz:
Ya bir tek dairenin içerisinde
ben benliğimle bunu doldurabilirim.
Ya da o deneyimimi her şeyimi dışarı alıp
bir şekilde ben o çemberlerin
sayısını çoğaltabilirim.
Sayısı onlarca ve yüzlerce olabilir.
Pek çok şeyi hayata geçirebilir.
Şimdi burada durup
bir soru sormak istiyorum.
Siz bu sürecin, yolculuğun,
çemberin neresindesiniz?
Bir nokta olarak hareket başlatmış
ve bunu büyütmek istersiniz.
Bunu büyütebilmek için
elbette bir çember oluşturacaksınız.
Ama onun içerisinde böyle dönüp
dolaşmayı bırakmanız lazım.
Belli bir adım sonra,
belli bir süre sonra,
onu yönetir hale gelip;
yönettikten sonra da
dışına çıkmanız gerekiyor.
Dışına çıktığınız yerde,
sizler yeni çemberler, yeni oluşumlar
ve sistemler kurmaya başlamış olacaksınız.
Hayat her gün çemberler kuruyor
ve her gün birilerini de bozuyor.
Bu sizin için gerçekleşmeden önce,
liderliği elinize alın, çemberler başlatın
ve çemberinizin dışına çıkarak çoğalın.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)